[Música]
hola bienvenidos a áfrica siete días
hasta su magazine 100% dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es andrés
meza muñoz y estos son nuestros
titulares
preocupación en áfrica occidental por
una ola de golpes de estado casi dos
semanas después de la toma del poder en
burkina faso guinea bissau vivió un
fallido golpe la unión africana condenó
la situación y dijo que no habrá
tolerancia con los que llamo militares
aventureros
este 6 de febrero se conmemoró el día
mundial de 'tolerancia cero' con la
mutilación genital femenina según las
naciones unidas- esta práctica se
concentró en unos 30 países de áfrica y
oriente medio les presentamos cuál es el
panorama en kenia donde la costumbre
afecta a casi el 98% de las jóvenes al
noreste del país
y senegal es el nuevo campeón de la copa
africana de naciones los leones de
lateral ya conquistaron su primer título
de este torneo al vencer a egipto en una
tanda de penales tenemos reportes de
nuestro enviado especial a camerún donde
se llevó a cabo la competencia
empezamos en áfrica occidental donde hay
preocupación por un patrón que se ha
vuelto repetitivo en la región militares
que detienen al presidente y luego se
hacen con el poder es lo que ha pasado
durante los últimos 18 meses en malí
guinea y este 2022 en burkina faso en
este último la destitución del
mandatario se dio en medio de un
creciente descontento entre los
militares ante la supuesta incapacidad
del gobierno para contener la violencia
de grupos yihadistas que empezó en 2015
y que ha obligado a más de 1.5 millones
de personas a huir de sus hogares al sur
de burkina faso unos 6000 ciudadanos han
encontrado refugio en costa de márfil
esta es la situación
algunas tiendas de campaña improvisadas
se ven a las afueras del pueblo de turbo
en el norte de costa de marfil
pertenecen a refugiados provenientes del
sur de burkina faso una región plagada
de violencia yihadista con llegaban en
moto con sus banderas negras nos decían
cómo debíamos practicar la religión que
podíamos y que no podíamos hacer
expulsadas de sus hogares estas familias
buscaron refugio en la vecina costa de
márfil a pocos kilómetros al sur dicen
que se sienten más seguros de este lado
de la frontera donde el ejército
marfileño mantiene una presencia militar
constante o que en casa nunca vimos al
ejército pero cuando llegamos aquí los
soldados vinieron a recibirnos ya
tranquilizar a
la mayoría de estos refugiados dejaron
todo atrás dependen de la ayuda del
gobierno marfileño de las naciones
unidas para salir adelante pero los
recursos son escasos y con pocas
oportunidades de empleo muchos están
luchando para llegar a fin de mes
encontramos un lugar para quedarnos pero
el problema es la comida se acabó el
dinero que traíamos no nos queda nada no
16 mil refugiados han llegado a tuvo en
los últimos seis meses destacando el
fracaso de burkina faso para contener la
crisis de seguridad en curso una
situación que la nueva junta militar del
país ha prometido abordar tras derrocar
el presidente rock kaboré
y es que sólo dos semanas después de la
toma del poder en burkina faso un
intento de golpe de estado se produjo en
la vecina guinea bissau el gobierno
anunció una investigación sobre el
frustrado ataque protagonizado por
hombres armados que atacaron el palacio
del gobierno mientras el presidente se
encontraba allí durante una cumbre anual
en etiopía los integrantes de la unión
africana abordaron la situación y
manifestaron que habrá tolerancia cero
para la ola golpista que ha sufrido el
continente no también de gestos de
áfrica de liniers en ningún momento de
la historia de la unión africana
habíamos tenido cuatro países en un año
calendario en 12 meses siendo
suspendidos
sin suspender malí guinea ciudad malí
guinea sudan y ahora burkina faso el
destino del día provecho de esta ocasión
esta oportunidad en sus deliberaciones
para condenar el intento de golpe de
estado contra el gobierno encabezado por
el presidente en valor de guinea bissau
obtiene pisado el domingo 6 de febrero
fue el día internacional de tolerancia
cero con la mutilación genital femenina
en 2021 naciones unidas estimó que
cuatro millones de mujeres kenianas
estaban en riesgo de sufrir esta
práctica cada año la mutilación genital
femenina se prohibió en 2011 y el
presidente keniata prometió que se
eliminaría por completo para 2022 pero
aunque el número de escisiones ha
disminuido en la última década todavía
persiste esta escuela alberga a niñas
que corren el riesgo de sufrir una
ablación genital
después de que la mutilaran cuando tenía
nueve años
grace encontró su refugio ahí
me atacaron por sorpresa me despertaron
en medio de la noche a las dos de la
mañana me obligaron a desnudarme y me
mutilaron con su buena ayuda en kenia
una de cada cinco niñas es víctima de
esta práctica
en este refugio el 90% de ellas tiene
entre 12 y 16 años
las chicas aquí conocen sus derechos
hablamos con ellos y les decimos lo que
tienen que hacer para que puedan venir
aquí la tasa de prevalencia de la
mutilación genital femenina ha
disminuido del 38 al 21 por ciento en 20
años a pesar de la prohibición de la
práctica desde 2011 algunos siguen
realizando la en secreto
enrique salem release es nuestro mayor
problema es que la mutilación genital es
una ceremonia tradicional está en el
corazón de su cultura y hacer que
alguien olvide su cultura no es fácil
las mujeres que viven de esta práctica
ganan hasta 18 dólares por mutilación
para dejar este oficio tienen que
encontrar otra fuente de ingresos como
la venta de collares tradicionales a los
turistas le deja callar en mi comunidad
todos los padres han aceptado el hecho
de que ya no tienen que mutilar a sus
hijas así que no hay razón para
preocuparse ahora las niñas pueden
volver a casa desde la escuela con
tranquilidad a pesar de los avances y de
las promesas del presidente de erradicar
esta práctica para 2022 las ong creen
que se tardará años en erradicar la
pasamos a república centroafricana en
pau a un pueblo ubicado al noroccidente
del país el cultivo de maní brinda
esperanza a sus residentes pero la
inseguridad en la región hace que los
cultivadores se vean forzados a vender
sus productos a muy bajo precio ya que
llevarlos hasta la capital del país
donde pueden costar hasta el triple
supone exponerse a grupos armados buscan
controlar las exportaciones
el maní es clave para la supervivencia
de los habitantes de la región de pawa
en la república centroafricana pero para
muchos cultivadores se trata de una
batalla diaria una cosecha debería ser
una buena noticia pero venderla supone
demasiados obstáculos
este año con la inseguridad hubo
demasiadas amenazas y robos tuvimos que
vender muy rápido y a precios bajos
ahora nos falta semilla para sembrar el
golpe sin igual a peso
la producción supera con creces la
demanda en la región lo que hace bajar
los precios mientras que en el pueblo un
costal vale unos diez mil francos que
equivale a unos 17 dólares en la capital
banguí ubicada a unos 500 kilómetros
puede valer el doble y hasta el triple
pero los productores no se atreven a
aventurarse hasta allí para vender el
producto temen los ataques de los grupos
rebeldes que expulsados de las grandes
ciudades libran una guerra contra las
fuerzas progubernamentales
una solución es procesar el maní y
venderlo a un precio más alto pero
extraer el aceite a mano es agotador y
los residentes locales no tienen el
capital para invertir en equipos
modernos
[Música]
el procesamiento aún se encuentra en una
etapa realmente artesanal necesitamos
tratar de apoyar la cadena y la
industria para desarrollar este proceso
y tratar de crear puntos y con sistemas
de grabación de producción de rayitas
y es que la necesidad es grande
república centroafricana es uno de los
países más pobres del mundo sumido en
una guerra civil desde el 2013 dos
tercios de la población de la región
carecen de comida según el programa
mundial de alimentos
la cría de felinos para su comercio está
amenazando a estas especies que ya se
encuentran en declive esa es la
principal conclusión de un informe
publicado por la ong for sports para la
protección de los animales este tipo de
comercios es especialmente frecuente en
sudáfrica según el mismo informe 359
tigres de granja fueron exportados desde
este país entre 2011 y 2020 y unos
255 fueron vendidos a zoológicos veamos
esta es una granja de tipo particular en
sudáfrica lejos de su espacio natural
encerrados detrás de bayas estos felinos
están destinados a ser vendidos en el
mercado internacional principalmente
asiático después de comercio de leones
el de tigres está floreciendo lo que
representa un peligro para la especie
pedimos a sudáfrica que ponga fin a la
cría comercial de graves felinos ya que
cada una de las cinco especies está en
declive en parte debido al comercio
internacional le dimos también a
sudáfrica que deje de apoyar este
mercado y que defienda la vida silvestre
los tigres no son nativos de sudáfrica y
tampoco se mencionan explícitamente en
la legislación de protección de los
animales
así que la pregunta es cómo ha florecido
este tipo de industria hasta este punto
es porque las autoridades no se tomaron
en serio una especie no autóctona de
sudáfrica o porque no se tomaron en
serio este mercado o simplemente las
autoridades han ignorado el problema
sudáfrica es el mayor exportador de
felinos en el mundo quedan unos 4000
tigres en libertad si estas especies en
gran peligro no se protegen algún día
sólo existirán en jaulas
vamos con noticias deportivas senegal
ganó su primera copa africana de
naciones tras vencer a egipto en una
ronda de penales las calles del país se
llenaron de júbilo ante la victoria de
los llamados leones de teranga desde
allá donde nuestro enviado especial
federico fue barberena con los detalles
final para la copa africana de naciones
y con un primer título africano para
senegal que se impuso en los penales a
egipto luego de una cerrada final que
terminó 0 a 0 fue victoria desde los 12
pasos para el elenco de los faraones
imponiéndose por 4 a 2 y con la
reivindicación de su mejor jugador de su
figura salio mané quien había fallado un
penal a los 6 minutos de juego y tuvo la
oportunidad de cerrar esa fase de
penales con el quinto remate y sellar el
marcador de 4-2 en favor de los leones
de la teranga que cierran de esta manera
un torneo que lo estuvo en un nivel de
menor a mayor
afectados al principio también por
varios casos de kobe 19 y llegando a su
pico de rendimiento sobre todo en los
partidos previos a esta final frente a
egipto aunque se la lleva merecidamente
también por haber sido el equipo que más
buscó el trofeo ha sido un torneo que
desde lo futbolístico quizás deja varias
cosas en el debe no no se ha mostrado no
han aparecido equipos o con grandísimos
niveles pero sí ha habido muchas
emociones y sobre todo sorpresas que se
dieron en las instancias iniciales como
la eliminación del último campeón del
que era el campeón defensor argelia o de
selecciones importantes como ganas y
también historias lindas entre esas de
los equipos pequeños que se hacen
fuertes como como horas el desarrollo de
gambia que llegó hasta los cuartos de
final o mismo de guinea ecuatorial el
único país de mayoría de habla hispana
en términos de organización un torneo
afectado y cruzado por el cómic 19 y las
restricciones que llevaron a que en los
estadios no siempre se vieran llenos y
que incluso en esta final no hubiera un
no se completara la capacidad
establecida en el estadio del mbe aún
así se despide una fiesta que se ha
vivido sobre todo en las calles para los
cameruneses que no tuvo el final deseado
por no haber logrado para ellos la final
aunque sí se llevaron ese partido por el
tercer puesto y en el devenir esta
defensa de la corona de egipto será
bastante corta porque la próxima copa
africana de naciones en costa de márfil
se jugará a mediados del próximo año
y finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días con las imágenes del artista
nigeriano bolu guatifó le dirán desde el
emperador napoleón hasta la reina isabel
segunda pasando por jesús el artista
cambia la complexión de sus modelos e
invita al público a cuestionar las
nociones de norma y poder los cuadros de
este joven pintor de 25 años demuestran
su empeño en reinterpretar pero sobre
todo revalorizar la identidad negra en
el imaginario político y religioso de
las grandes pinturas clásicas
occidentales
de esta manera despedimos este episodio
de áfrica siete días recuerden que si
quieres repetir en esta u otra emisión
de nuestro programa lo pueden hacer a
través de nuestra página web www punto
francisco 4 punto com
[Música]